so do everyone know who Jeff Bezos is
Auntie you don't Amazon guy Amazon I
don't know if Amazon it's like one of
the so he's one of the richest
he's one of the richest men on the
planet
um and so about a couple years ago it
came out that he was cheating on his
wife at the time and his wife was there
from the beginning so she was like
they've been together I don't know like
20 years something like that and she
divorced him
took half the money and got remarried
and at the time everyone was saying I
was so sweet she married a teacher
and it all seemed like you know she got
the fairy tale ending however
she is now divorcing her second husband
so knowing that women typically don't do
well
um
when they date someone that's like less
than their their EX in their head should
she have stayed with Jeff
knowing that she can't do better
what
I think Bill Gates didn't he get
divorced yeah yeah I guess you wouldn't
have known she can't do better until she
we know people think you know the grass
is greener and if you're in that Circle
like you're I guess you're what you're
that like the people you're you've got
accessible to you know are different
you're in a different war game like is
that you know when you feed a celebrity
I am now in this world I've got access
to I've been in this I guess so she
wouldn't have known she couldn't do
better when she's already in that world
like what's it I mean what she knows
that now but she probably falls on her
so she probably thought it's better to
date why did they why did they split up
because he cheated it's
he stepped out how do you know maybe she
weren't giving him no six
but she could have forgiven him talk
about it look how long they've been
together they've been together but you
were saying that if a woman stays she's
stupid then so if she stayed with him
after he cheated would she not be stupid
and look what she done and look what she
done made more of a fool of herself she
might as well stay there Auntie didn't
Auntie didn't say you're stupid she says
the girls are stupid when they get back
with the guy and then complain about him
cheating so like you you make his life a
living hell you chose to get back with
him and maybe yeah maybe yeah maybe she
couldn't figure you couldn't let go yeah
so she has to leave maybe she's just
thinking about the money she would get
if she divorce him that she could start
again I think that but she should have
gonna find another billionaire to match
her money then I I do think he was wrong
though because I do I do believe that if
a woman was there from the start then
you owe her that level of loyalty for
helping you get to the position you got
to I only believe that if he remarries
or finds a new woman then he just do the
[ __ ] you like because she's buying into
a lifestyle that she can never have and
she's got lucky I want to know if she
gets divorced or she got get the teacher
off oh no of course not she'll be smart
to do prenup just checking yeah she
would I hope she did a peanut oh [ __ ]
smart enough why do you hope she do the
prenup so it's nice for her to take that
but it's not nice to someone to do it to
her yeah because it was there in the
beginning didn't help her from the
beginning did he exactly
she didn't get that money from the
beginning yeah she helped her husband
but that's why she got what she got but
she didn't like yeah yeah she didn't
make the money she took care of the
family she did her yeah but is that come
on half his fortune you're telling me if
it was her she could have built Amazon
by herself no she she didn't do that but
you know the thing is that was their
partnership right that was what they
worked together it's like it's like men
when they used to pay off the mortgage
when women then divorced they were
entitled to laugh only because they
couldn't earn and they wouldn't exactly
I held it down for you to build that
fortune yeah you know the thing is Right
entitled to his money like that's so
much like I'm just thinking from the
man's point of view like if I'm building
this business right and I and I have a
like I have a boyfriend or husband right
why why would he leave and get half if I
built it so why do women feel entitled
because with them here say say they've
got children he obviously had to work
like tirelessly to build Amazon right
she was probably I don't know I don't
know the situation I know the story but
let's just say she was at home she held
down the home for him to be able to to
build that I definitely it's not it's
not worth half of Amazon you know it's
billions of dollars you have to raise
two kids oh come on I know something I
grew up with nannies I grew up with
nannies that shit's like 12 an hour
or whatever but knowing a woman staying
at home to take care of kids is hard
work no that's why you had nannies
otherwise
billions of dollars you know the thing
is right is that she got half his money
But the teacher I would like to see what
he does with his half because Amazon's
still going to stay there I bet he still
makes more money than she does with hers
a bit sooner or later she's got no money
and he's still building on this she
wants to give her money away that'd be
cool then she shouldn't have taken it in
the first place
in the first place if you're not gonna
want it no that's different I can take
money from you and then give it to
whoever I want to give and spend however
I want to spend it but I'm not going to
decline the money because I'm going to
give it away I'd like to see it I don't
think she should give it away can I say
I think just Jeff Bezos doesn't give a
[ __ ] how about that because simply
because that's his ex-wife and she got
half the money but he's got his money
and you know this is going to make more
that's not right to see he don't give a
[ __ ] because it's Jeff Bezos the average
man has to give a [ __ ] because that's
his livelihood done I get you but this
is all in context of the situation I
don't think Jeff Bezos
he doesn't care because at the end of
the day maybe she said okay what about
this what about this would you rather
you lose your money yeah but and you
don't have to deal with that woman
that's weighing you down for the rest of
your life and you can make some more
money and be happy and content I I agree
with you he's so rich he probably I
doubt he cares yeah he's so rich but but
the point is like why why do as women we
feel entitled to a man's money because
you helped raise the kid no but that's a
lot in the states right this doesn't
apply like in most other okay but we're
not we're in the UK even in the UK women
don't naturally that's not right
that's not true um even I don't
necessarily know what it is for divorce
but from I've heard a lot of like I get
DMS from people constantly and I've
gotten horror stories from Men in the UK
and I I do Street interviews horror
stories of Child Support so it's it's no
different and it's you're in the west
we're not talking about global if I have
to give up my career for you to build
something and then you cheat on me and
we have to get divorced big man give me
my money
because you feel like a ways but that's
how the courts see it the courts see it
as it's fair for a woman to get this
like we're saying about the West the
reason that this is a law is because the
courts have decided not women that it's
fair for women especially where they
couldn't maybe have an income
no but the context is the court
men pay
and then women claim legal aid which is
taxpayers money which men are the
taxpayers because they're working right
then what happens is is basically women
get half of the man's money because he's
working he has to pay the legal fees he
has to pay child support which also goes
to the woman and then there's a level of
entitlement that women as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible